block wurf wir schreiben den 21 08 2005
10 339 der road trip beginnt wir sind
auf dem weg nach berlin
ich bin um elf heute aus köln
zurückgekommen elf uhr nachts haben wir
eine stunde geschlafen ca im auto auf
den weg nach berlin
20 nach acht morgens ist die
prognostizierte anfangszeit
ist bei amazon co hamburg ist nur mehr
wenig von maine v6 wir haben noch 345 km
vor uns bis berlin ich bin gerade eben
einfach weg gepennt wenn ich mir den
softbox die idee natürlich ganz gut
wo hier raus ich meine stunde gepennt
oder so einfach seht ihr das es findet
einfach so findet sage ich es
übertrieben neblig ist richtig betrieben
nämlich waren sie echt fucking wenig von
ihm eines tages in panik auf
der ace combat irgendwo bei jena wir
haben jetzt im fünften versuch ist
tatsächlich geschafft eine stelle zu
finden so ist genau was es hier gibt
wenn ich krank ich glaube dass ich meine
tankstelle tankstelle haben wir nicht
gefunden dafür aber ein sehr sehr sehr
leckeren latte macchiato der auch nur
den preis eines einfamilienhauses
gekostet hat an dieser nebligen
haltestelle ist echt ein schönes setting
gerade der nebel kommt gar nicht so gut
durch auf der kamera aber es ist richtig
richtig cool aber wir können nicht immer
bleiben deswegen beck und werden wir
auch in berlin angekommen
ich muss gestehen dass ich die letzte
zeit nur geschlafen hab ich habe
versucht ein stück zu fahren aber es
ging einfach überhaupt nicht und man
sollte so krass überlegen ich auch kein
auto fahren
deswegen habe ich das steuer noch mal
abgegeben wir haben jetzt kann man das
lesen
29 wir sind in berlin kommen aus berlin
heute so zu bieten hat oder es ein
kleines blatt es ist jetzt 13 uhr 40 wir
haben die letzten vier stunden
verfrühstückt verschlafen und sonst
irgendwie rumgehangen weil so eine
autofahrt einen schon ziemlich schlaucht
jetzt wirds aber zeit dass sie mal
rausgehen wir werden das einkaufen
werden noch gab es vielleicht trainieren
gehen aber dafür wird einfach viel zu
krass aber wir haben ein problem und
zwar weiß ich nicht wie ich diesen blog
schneiden soll ich habe kein laptop
dabei ich muss vielleicht zu einem
berliner kollegen dann von mir geh und
dadurch den videos schneiden aber dass
wenn wir später sehen
als erstes
gemälde und schnell
habt es bequemer
ok
ich meine mit group of companies fährt
britische comicbuch so einkäufe erledigt
wir jetzt kurz duschen und dann starten
wir die stadt endlich müsst ihr auch mal
nutzen das werk in berlin sind es 14 uhr
ich habe immer noch keine ahnung
wichtigen heutigen blog schneiden werde
wir finden den wegen jetzt fest mutter
an den fisch war schockiert es wird
spannend ich habe jetzt gerade auf
twitter gefragt ob irgendjemand in
berlin schnittprogrammen und noch ein
gute internetleitung hat damit dieser
blog heute noch online kommen kann und
die julia von menschen tv kommen das
lesen hat gemeint sie würde jemanden
kennen und eventuell klappt es ist
einfach richtig behindert aber was soll
man machen wir haben kein pc und der der
gute mann ist ob ich kann nur back down
auf twitter und vielleicht vielleicht
klappt es ja und wir können dann bei dem
karten an hochladen das wäre richtig
krass bad jetzt gerade darauf dass sie
mir irgend adresse durch gibt und dann
können wir da hinfahren vielleicht
wirklich da einfach steine hochladen
die leute ganz adresse wir haben eine
handynummer wir machen es auch zum alex
da in der nähe ist wohl jemand bei dem
wir das video schneiden können und
hochladen können
also packen
so weit es die schmerzen sylvie gelebten
corporate travel leisure depression
afrika liegt es aber ernst
hallo liebe helfer des von der cvp hofft
nun die bande busch und svb die
conficker niger hat vor der export des
juve die hauptinvestoren nun gibt er
biete man nur schon des new deal
es sind tatsächlich geklappt wir sind
jetzt hier in der wohnung von leona ist
sehr gute werte vermittelt leonskaja um
die ecke des bisschen kamerascheu auf
jeden fall guckt euch das hier an der
blüte mehr sein komplettes set up zum
schneidern richtig gut und zum hoch
waren auch noch also danke dich
die beiden sind verlinkt julia
mitmenschen tv und leon mit der back
down gerne mal vorbeischauen abonnieren
das war's von heute mit diesem
abenteuerlichen blog ich hoffe euch
gefallen
der erste teil ist roadtrips wenn das so
ist dann das gerne daumen nach oben
wir sind zunächst wieder wiederholt drei
macht's gut und